it's Thursday October thirtieth and
you're watching gamespot news Chris
waters here yes I survived the night of
the San Francisco Giants World Series
victory thank you for your concern and
as a reward for your thoughtfulness I
shall deliver unto you the news it's
been three weeks since the launch of the
PlayStation 4 exclusive racer drive club
and it still doesn't work right though
developer evolution studios has issued
regular updates things have gotten so
bad that playstation president of
worldwide studios Shuhei Yoshida has
apologized in a Facebook post he also
commented on the lack of the promised
free playstation plus version saying
with the high volume of new players an
additional server load that the PS plus
edition is anticipated to bring we are
currently not confident that we can
guarantee the best online experience
until we can ensure that everyone can
enjoy the full social connected online
experience we will be postponing the
release of the PS Plus edition until
further notice that's not the only Sony
whoa on today's show though the latest
system update renamed standby mode to
rest mode but it's turning out to be
more like sleep of the Dead mode on many
consoles as they do not power back on
after entering rest mode fortunately you
can boot in safe mode if this happens to
you by holding down the power button for
like seven seconds and Sony is working
to fix both this and the YouTube issues
that some users are experiencing on the
bright side for Sony the ps4 is proving
to be the place to play Ubisoft games
according to a recent earnings report
from Ubisoft over the past six months
thirty-two percent of ubisoft game
purchased work for the PlayStation 4
with the xbox one only tallying 15%
falling behind the PlayStation 3 which
was responsible for seventeen percent do
you think that holiday Xbox one bundle
with two Assassin's Creed games will do
anything to change that ratio let us
know what you think in the comments
below and finally details have been
released about the first full expansion
for the totally excellent tolkien's
Creed I mean middle-earth shadow of
mordor a little joke i like to make
about the game kind of bezel screw you
I'm sorry the lord of the hunt dlc
introduces a new beast master war chief
along with some new story missions new
law courtesy of tour
in the Dwarven hunter new nemec's new
runes and a bunch of other new stuff but
I think the highlight for me personally
has to be this one ride into battle on
the wretched growl to vomit toxin at
your foes you basically get to ride a
barf Beast how cool is that the answer
is very cool that was a rhetorical
question that's it for this episode tune
in tomorrow when I'll be back to round
up the top five news stories of the week
and probably make some doofy Halloween
jokes and maybe look for some ghosts
with the Kinect because that's the thing
people do for real